[Musik]
dass fox bis fuß eigentlich erfüllt wird
an die architektur bei mir ja der c
strafen wie es sehr stark du bist eine
ständige kontrolle das ist dass sie
womöglich alles abgestimmt über sport
[Musik]
fabian und aline sie waren jahrelang im
schweizer nationalkader
synchronschwimmen sie haben an welt und
europameisterschaften teilgenommen
sie sind drei von vielen athletinnen die
in den letzten monaten mit uns
gesprochen und abkühlen der im schweizer
sport aufgezeigt haben die frage die
sich stellt was läuft falsch im
synchronschwimmen
[Musik]
der hand geschichts für zähler es würde
mich wundern
warum pakete zyklus
sicherlich dass es für die jüngere
generation antritt und wenn dieses
problem hält wenn er
zurückblickt dass alle wissen dass sie
nicht alle ist sie mit dem riesigen zur
großen worten und jetzt
am anfang war die faszination
[Musik]
so
wird auch mit dem ganzen körper schaffen
gleichzeitig danken einfach aber gleich
die die emotionen
alle drei sind im kanton bern
aufgewachsen alle drei haben schon in
jüngsten jahren mit synchronschwimmen
begonnen
bald kamen die ersten wettkämpfe
[Musik]
sportschuh gange und die zuschauer so
genommen habe bestimmt worden meldet hat
der blogger kaufen meinte zum audi auch
die auffangnetz training wir sind 12
liegen sie mit didaktischen vom 20 4
papiere direkt das training
morgen
schubkarrenrennen sonst kriegt sie
direkt ins training morgen training
oder wettkampf nachdem
[Gelächter]
synchronschwimmen verlangt von den
mädchen und jungen frauen extrem viel ab
die trainings sind oft hart nicht selten
über seitliche maß hinaus
das
steuer der schlacht gemacht hat dass da
geschoben wird
vier stunden training extrem
einfach so
es ist auch davor dass wenn man mich
fragt trend ist eine pause macht schnaps
trinkt als kate
nash wert ist und das perfekte und am
schluss ist der schlusspunkt
das passiert ist
körperliche reduziert sie sagt es
wirklich sinnvoll
vom ganzen
volk
verloren
sie hat einfach so den blick wenn sie
sich
was macht dieser sport mit jungen frauen
und ihrer beziehung zum eigenen körper
das wollte auch nothelfer genauer wissen
und schrieb ihre maturaarbeit über das
thema essstörungen im synchronschwimmen
dazu verschickte sie fragebogen und
schweizer trainerinnen und schwimmen
passiert
es ist offensichtlich in diesem sport
gibt es grundsätzliche probleme auch in
bezug aufs essen mit gravierenden folgen
für die athletinnen
ich glaube dass ich die personalsorgen
und welche kommentare hat
übertrifft hat das ist nicht so
ausgiebig und
[Musik]
deshalb
habe er als neofonie
[Musik]
dem spiel
ja und
ich so
schlecht
gespielt
aber
das fazit ihrer maturarbeit die
trainerinnen haben einen großen einfluss
darauf ob junge athletinnen eine
ungesunde beziehung zum essen entwickeln
die
branche muss dafür dass der sport machen
aber gleichzeitig nicht ausweisen musste
so muss ein ästhetisches zeit in muskeln
salon sie mit co2 als die payback diesen
konsumenten und migros mit dem salon abs
noch bevor es eigentlich auch gelobt
worden und hat stets etwa das modell das
man schon andere dinge aber zeichnete
kosten weil
dazu kommt körperliche gewalt die für
viele synchronschwimmerinnen noch immer
zum trainingsalltag gehört flaschen
anwerfen klemmen und vor allem das
gewaltsame dienen
das
passiert und zwar um ethische
und zwar ist es auf dem rückweg lage
macht so viel dass sie mit die sparpläne
und ich bin die trainerin mit ihrem
ganzen gewicht auf ihre oberschenkel
probleme und
zur sache und der ist einfach kurz
diskontierten trennen
minute
wenn du
trainierst
ersetzt werden in der chiemgau arena
aber zum thema vier reserve zum teil 2
also interesse
wenn der ece stück ich vielleicht hatte
sollte schiebt liegen das heißt dass der
gummi nach wunsch
[Musik]
die emotionen kontrollieren lächeln
trotz allem wie hier an der wm in q2
2009 10 mit dem team alle kämpfer
[Musik]
wenn das mehrheit der nokia-aktie
verletzungen meine tochter ist
fahrlässig sie also wo du hast ganz xq
krise wodurch der schulter gucken wo
immer der spitze der box das ist eine
sache die rücksicht nehmen sie sind es
14 blitz und donner internet ich habe
der 5 telefon machen dass da über
details zu dem ausruf sind und die zum
teil panik kann das ist doch nicht
normal als sie das ist nichts neues sie
wird hauptsächlich
strenger
frost
talkshows oder was weiß ich
dass meine fraktion tische in der
schlitzer
es geht es meinen geschwistern
also war sehr heiß ist das tor keine
chance ließ gar die angst vor der lage
dank warum machen aber
es steht also außer stehen wenn man
nicht beschädigt man ist erstaunt
das fand ich es gar nicht schwer war
anja schmidt
und ich lust konnte
also ich glaub mir so
was im training passiert man in eine
domäne mit dann beschäftige sondern
probiere so gut über
[Musik]
telefon
gemacht
und sich ganz gespannt so
die trainerinnen die srf investigativ
mit den vorwürfen konfrontiert hat
wollen keine stellung nehmen es betrifft
auch nicht alle trainerinnen in der
schweiz aber doch offenbar so viele dass
von einem systemischen problem
auszugehen ist
was immer wieder angesprochen wird die
osteuropäische und russische trainings
mentalität
großes jahr mit abstand die beste und
das große haut anders tritt wert und
anders trainiert weil das ist welche sie
lehnten ein ziemlich schnell
erste-chef und so und sie hat nicht
sagen ja mehr verlagerte der russen
weiter aus und diese wird vor spiel
perfekt mit
75 verbunden sind und alle möglichen
tiere und wenn sie sind ja die
trainieren sie schaffe es wieso
also dem euro
die große frage stellt warum wird man
nicht einfach und doch gesagt du
wirst
während der funktioniert und wie
searches in frage das ist eine wirklich
so schlecht
da aber dadurch das ganze aber dafür
eigentlich umstellt okay der sportshow
dadurch
dass man mit dem zug
natürlich
das ist wirklich familie
nicht
identifizierte mit ganz vielen
hobby
im herbst 2020 gab es schon einmal einen
riesigen knall im schweizer sport im
kunstturnen und in der rhythmischen
sportgymnastik wurden missstände
aufgedeckt die sogenannten magglingen
protokolle es gab einen aufschrei die
politik reagierte bundesrätin viola
amherd zeigte sich persönlich betroffen
für mich war klar dass wir diese
vorfälle nicht tolerieren dürfen und
dass wir alles daran setzen müssen dass
so etwas in zukunft nicht mehr vorkommt
bundesrätin am herd rief eine neue
beschwerdestelle ins leben und auch ein
gutachten gab es in auftrag dieses zeigt
der grobe verstöße in mehreren
sportarten und wörtlich artistik
swimming sowjet synchronschwimmen
offiziell genannt schnitt am
schlechtesten ab
im gutachten ist die rede von
signifikant höheren werten psychischer
gewalt etwa anschreien beschimpfen drohe
auch physische gewalt wird der welt
anzügliche bemerkungen und
dauerbelastungen am schluss heißt es im
artistik swimming bestehe grundsätzlich
handlungsbedarf das war im letzten
herbst aus das gutachten des bundes auch
zeigt viele synchronschwimmerinnen
werden nebst allem anderen auch
vernachlässigt und ignoriert als strafe
im training oder wenn sie mit 17 18
plötzlich aus zu alt gelten oder
vielleicht auch aus zu faul ich dann
werden sie aufs abstellgleis geschoben
wie medien
und technologie kann so natürlich mit
circa club
angefangen hat das möchte ich gar nicht
verbrauchte im training
und einfach mit dieser top trainerin
training bei dem verein im vorstand und
drohnen häcksler denn sie hat mamis vor
schwimmerin rechte ab macht hat ziemlich
aus nun um die
schwimmende nicht verstanden wurde
prüft einfach abgelehnt wurde obwohl
große ziel hexa und unserer besten form
sexy und aus plötzlich hat man einfach
der körper wollte ich meinem sich
freiwillig im club occ
fabian und aline haben in der folge den
verein gewechselt
von baum zu baum
karrieremäßig sei es für sie als
nationalkader schwimmerinnen trotzdem
abwärts gegangen sagen sie
das ist
schon frustrierend
sei eigentlich
ausgeführt dass das image und die
richter kenner und es würde die club
wachsen in mich gegangen und zu
beschneiden
der verein synchro bern weist in einer
stellungnahme die vorwürfe zurück es
lägen überhaupt keine anhaltspunkte für
eine verletzung von verhaltensregeln vor
die schwimmerinnen seien damals im
besten auto und somit keineswegs zu alt
gewesen sie hätten zu den westen des
vereins gehört und es habe kein
interesse bestanden
ahlen verließen für den verein wäre es
eine herzensangelegenheit eine
versöhnliche lösung zu finden der
vorstand habe sich sehr um eine
aussprache bemüht leider seien
gesprächstermine mehrfach kurzfristig
abgesagt worden
auch die vorwürfe dass kinder von
vorstandsmitgliedern bevorzugt würden
oder trainerinnen psychische und
physische gewalt anwendeten werden
zurückgewiesen solches würde der verein
nicht dulden
wir haben mit vielen aktiven und
ehemaligen synchronschwimmerinnen aus
der ganzen schweiz gesprochen die
meisten erzählen sehr ähnliches dazu
gehören auch vorwürfe die tief in die
strukturen des synchronschwimmen blicken
lassen es geht um vetternwirtschaft etwa
um eltern und trainerinnen die an
wettkämpfen auch ausrichter werden
soviel tag der logistik hat jedes kind
also für den verein und nicht auf das
ist eigentlich
für die
premiere
am
sport
es ist
verkehrt und
das bemerkenswerte ist die probleme sind
offiziell festgehalten srf investigativ
liegen interne dokumente des
schwimmverbands fuhr in einem schreiben
vom mai ist beispielsweise die rede vom
katastrophalen niveau bei den richtern
eigene vereine würden systematisch und
hemmungslos bevorteilt ebenso eigene
athletinnen der verband schreibt von
chaos querelen unzumutbaren
arbeitsbedingungen die administrative
arbeit bleibe größtenteils unbearbeitet
die planungsarbeit systematisch zu spät
brisant schon im letzten sommer schreibt
der schwimmverband von großer sorge um
die zukunft von artistik swimming es
herrsche seit jahren ein klima der
missgunst unter anderem im fokus die
beiden co sportdirektoren die innerhalb
des schwimmverbands für
synchronschwimmen zuständig sind markus
thöni und patricia fahrni beide
verbunden mit zwei der größten vereine
in der schweiz zürich und morsch beide
sind aus eltern reingerutscht auch
vorwürfe von vereinen und athletinnen
aus dem nationalkader sind heftig
vetternwirtschaft chaos inkompetenz die
beiden co sportdirektoren haben zu den
vorwürfen schriftlich stellung genommen
dort heißt es die psychische und
physische gesundheit der athletinnen
habe oberstes gebot es sei nach dem
gutachten des bundes ein maßnahmenplan
erstellt worden zug aus und querelen
schreiben markus töne und patricia farny
sie hätten das anders erlebt die
zusammenarbeit mit den vereinen sei
konstruktiv zum vorwurf der
systematischen und hemmungslosen
bevorteilung könnten sie keine stellung
nehmen weil ihnen keine konkreten fälle
bekannt sei auch betonen beide etliche
vorwürfe würden die jahre vor ihrer wahl
im april 20 21 betreffen
kurz nach dieser stellungnahme haben
markus töne und patricia fahren ihren
rücktritt bekanntgegeben
der verband selber hatte schon zuvor
beschlossen die ganze sportart eine
analyse zu unterziehen wie
verbandspräsident jugend cameron sagt
durch rücktritt kann aber jetzt
unbedacht vorherige geschichte vor der
situation
grund für die endfällige wo uns der
brecht hoffnung wird liefere die
sportart neu strukturieren neu
aufstellen der organisationsform das
personal und der firma ruhe in das ganze
netz bringen
dass das ganze system synchronschwimmen
nicht funktioniert haben auch alina nook
und fabienne zu spüren bekommen sie
hatten sich nicht nur beim verein in
bern beschwert sondern auch bei den ko
sportdirektoren bei der verbandseigenen
beschwerdestelle und beim verband selber
viele mails seien geschrieben worden
passiert sei letztlich wenig verein und
schwimmverband betonen heute man würde
die angelegenheit nach wie vor gerne auf
gute art lösen
das wäre getroffen das ist absurd
so sei in der krise keine rede und das
ganze problem schildert klare
möglichkeit dar um irgendwelche
maßnahmen und regelungen
nimmt
frau muss man einfach mit der sache
abschließen
das ist jetzt
meine zwei jahren hat sich das jetzt
sogar nicht nur der schwimmverband
erscheint passiv auch die neue
beschwerdestelle swissport integrity die
bundesrätin am herd ins leben rief und
die seit januar in betrieb ist scheint
wenig niederschwellig
[Musik]
synchronschwimmerin und ich eigentlich
gar nicht
erzählt also das ist auch sehr energie
immer wieder also frist immer wieder die
gleiche geschichte zu erzählen die
wiederum hat eigentlich jeder stellt
jetzt werde ich mach jetzt dass damit
auch möglich geschützt sind also zählt
kann ich sie nicht aber das ist
eigentlich ein teil von dem ganzen
für die
100 mails gefiltert
telefon
und immer mit viel hoffnung es nahm sich
ebenfalls zu
bis heute hat swissport integrity viele
mails geschrieben aber so sagen fabiana
luke und aline sie haben die drei
athletinnen nicht einmal selber angehört
ernst könig ist direktor von swissport
integrity er kennt den fall aber ihm
seien die hände gebunden
obwohl die drei athletinnen bis vor
kurzem noch im nationalkader schwammen
liegt der knatsch mit dem verein zu weit
zurück seit ich stand vor mir
stürzte hatte sich rasch in kraft seit
dem ersten januar hat und darum ist es
sie dass die vorfälle außerhalb von
einem extra 3 stattgefunden und ist ein
grund für diese zuständigkeit siegerin
juristisch im recht trotzdem und ich mir
wichtig zu betonen meine trotzdem das
ist eigentlich mit diesem
zuständigkeitsbereiche scheint sehr
große anstrengungen und nova team sind
mit der sache analysiert
mitte zwischen der zwischen den parteien
und am schluss ich halte das nach
ajaccio dass das nicht
fruchtet um es dort gleich eine zügige
einigung haben ist denn sie sind
nachvollziehbar dass junge athletin nach
eigener aussage stoßen die sachen erlebt
hat sagt sie fühle sich mit lost und sie
fühlen sich
ja das kann ich sehr gut nachvollziehen
absolut und es ist wichtig dass man die
situation wie ein schweizer dass man die
kritik mit darf und so muss sogar immer
wieder muss das kritisiert aber genau
rechtliche grundlage habe tatsache dass
es aber so dass man ihre situation sie
die zeigt dass wird es immer angenehm
sie im spitzensport aber die muss
natürlich auch sagen dass man probiert
hat das jetzt fliegt sie mit ideen
andere situation weil die forscher
basiert denn ist für ist ganz klar den
sie mir zuständig und ein handy und
besucht und da kommt so verständlich vor
den opfern zu ich das gefühl du bist
verpasste karriere bakterien
also weiter
in sachen sicherheit bietet
sie und große wettkampf mit den
nationalen renault ja das ist ein
wenn der bauer jahr verabschiedet und
die waren synchronschwimmen was würdet
ihr ihnen sagen es
ist so cool dass zu machen aber mit dem
kran ganze drum muss ich sagen dass
michael abbott
fabian ist im märz zurückgetreten
seither hat sie ihrem zimmer fast keine
erinnerungen und synchronschwimmen mehr
nur wenige fotos sind geblieben und die
frage ob sie etwas verpasst habt
ja so schaut mehr aus einfach als hobby
steht
hier also
wirklich
das land ist jetzt nehmen wir die die
nachstehend das ist für uns natürlich
wenn du im training
habe ich ein menschenleben oder dem
schlaf oder sie hat motor fahren für it
training oder so war damals schon
der schläger verschmelzen verbraucht mit
mit dem team als mit der richtige
familie so
für ihn hat ein neuer lebensabschnitt
angefangen
einer indem sie nun plötzlich viel zeit
hat zeitung zurück zu schauen aber vor
allem auch zeit um vorwärts zu schauen
[Musik]
boock wollte weit weg von der schweiz
und vom synchronschwimmen also ist sie
anfang jahr für einen sprachaufenthalt
in die usa gereist
mit bill mail ihrem großen vorbild einer
amerikanischen synchronschwimm legende
hat sie nun nach ein paar monaten
auszeit wieder angefangen zu trainieren
[Musik]
und überlegt sich für den cirque du
soleil zu bewerben dort gibt es eine
wassershow namens in der ihr
trainingspartner belange zur besetzung
führte
harte arbeit sagt bill aber die könne
durchaus spaß machen
dieser sport lässt sich ständig wachsen
er ist er irrt sich du siehst immer
deutlicher was du besser machen kannst
und du wirst künstlerische aus gefordert
das führt zu immer neuer motivation
an der westküste der usa
südlich von san francisco ist auf der
suche nach etwas was sie abhanden
gekommen ist nach der leidenschaft für
den tanz im wasser
also hier ist jetzt 60 meter der männer
freud für bundes und auch wenn die
letzten jahren wenn ich zurückblicke wie
krieg und die sache einfach nur wenig
gefragt mach das jetzt hier und wenn es
mal gar strang für mich macht mehr
freude und so dass sie mit dem bild und
solcher trainiere schon mal geschlossen
hat freut
zurückgezahlt
die armee muss zur arbeit aus übernimmt
hätte carrasco sie hat in den 90er
jahren für die usa eine olympische
goldmedaille im synchronschwimmen
gewonnen
[Musik]
elop will wieder in topform kommen für
ihre bewerbung beim zirkus sonne dafür
brauche es vor allem motivation nicht
demütigung sagt ihre trainerin
manchmal muss man seine stimme heben
damit sie etwas ein bisschen besser oder
genauer im takt machen wenn man es ihnen
immer und immer wieder sagt dann wird
man schon mal an geklauter das kann
helfen wenn man es in einer positiven
art tut aber
ich denke definitiv nicht dass es den
scheinbar ihnen hilft bessere athlet
ihnen zu werden wären sie an scheint
[Musik]
in den usa hat auch das chinesische
essen für sich entdeckt
heute sagt ihr niemand mehr was sie
davon was nicht da ist jetzt vereint sie
kann tun und lassen und ja auch essen
moss zivil
eine ganz neue erfahrung für die heute
21-jährige und manchmal auch eine
überforderung
es ist wohl auf die einzigen produkte
anders sieht es stress eigentlich schon
weil wir aber so frei wie und mini im
luftring gelegt und benny ist
groß
frei sein und sich frei fühlen das ist
nicht das gleiche
noch nicht
vor ihr